yeah I'm wearing that lootcrate shirt
you know labyrinth lootcrate shirt that
i see everybody wear like every time I'm
in the mall there's like 23 people
wearing this shirt then it shows the
lengths of my laziness pop star never
stop never stopping so pop star is a
mockumentary starring Andy Samberg and
his musical crew you know the guys who
sang the Jack Sparrow Michael Bolton
music video yeah then Andy Samberg in
this movie plays a Justin Bieber
esque pop star named Connor for real who
is unfortunately for him falling down
the precipice of obscurity and he's
dealing with it how someone named Connor
for real but deal the situation like
that seriously it's like if Justin
Bieber and Miley Cyrus had a love child
who became a pop star and they started
fading into obscurity that he is Connor
for real and his movies presented in a
comedic documentary style way completely
works for this movie what I really like
about it is they have all these
celebrities and musical personalities in
the interview process they're all like
oh man I love Connor for real I mean
they're talking about it and they're
talking about him it gives us movie
three dimensions it really pulls you in
you're like this Connor for real
is a real person in real life he
completely works for this movie I was
laughing throughout this movie
undeniably and there were a couple of
scenes man I was laugh out loud
hysterically laughing kind of funny I
haven't seen Andy Samberg in the zone
like this for quite some time and now
you see him again you're like oh yeah
you're funny I used to watch his comedy
music videos all the time is SNL scare
the dick in the box like me and a
co-worker at my old job we watch that
every day look at work probably not
supposed to do that but we did it it's
no surprise and there's no denying that
we in the world have a fascination with
celebrities and their weird drama
because they just they don't deal with
it like normal people they deal with it
like five-year-olds with a lot of money
so when a movie comes along and so
successfully captures the absurdity of
how they act it's just that they can be
hysterical it can be or it can be stupid
as this one is hysterical because
it's done by a crew who obviously they
know that world but they're not wrapped
up in that world like yeah I'll make fun
doesn't matter but really baffled me
about this movies like Andy Samberg is
an in the movie so you should
never
really actually side with them but you
empathize with him to a surprising
degree it's like he almost pity him and
it is a hard thing for a movie to
portray someone like a crybaby spoiled
manchild and in the end have you
empathize with him and pity him be like
yeah you have everything but you really
have nothing cuz I was thoroughly
entertained in this movies one of those
movies you can watch in theaters and you
pay for it and you have a good time you
walk out yeah yeah I enjoyed that movie
how great is that I mean you're gonna be
flipping through your channels you're
gonna find it you holy it's that
pop star alright let's watch it it's
like a fun surprise when it's on TV as
you're searching for something to watch
you're gonna pop it on you're gonna
watch it again the downside of this
movie is its predictable as hell there's
nothing groundbreaking in the narrative
from start to finish you kind of see
where the movies going and so you know
exactly where it's gonna end and it ends
exactly there and that is pretty
formulaic doesn't change the fact that
you're having a good time with this
movie and you're laughing your ass off
in this movie guys I'm like the floating
guy in Mary Poppins I love to laugh and
this movie made me laugh I had a great
time with it I'm going to say pop star
is definitely a good time no ass all
required I want to see a sequel but I
don't really want to see a sequel just I
hope they do the Borat thing where Andy
Samberg does other mockumentary that are
really unlinked we'll see what happens
but I feel like Andy Samberg in his crew
they might get some momentum from this
so they should keep going with that
momentum right so pop star have you seen
it what did you think about it what's
your favorite mockumentary of all time
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]